the tampa bay rays it's gonna be
right-hander tyler glass now making his
fifth start of the season the perfect
record the era under one how about this
24 and two-thirds innings and tyler
glass now has given up just two earned
runs cam invention is going to lead it
off
and
cut the miss he blows it by him
95 98
99 up you can't catch up now beau buchet
and that is strike three call
99 some low heat right there
back to back strikeout two up two down
and here is guerrero
ground ball toward the middle that's
going to go through into center field
and so he's on base again he's been on
base in every toronto game this year
here's the dh or audi telez
that one is headed toward the alley into
right center field
that's got some carry and will bound off
the wall
they're going to score guerrero and into
second base goes to less and toronto
will take a one-nothing lead here in the
first first and second two down toles at
second grechek at first and here is
marcus simeon
that's a shot
well tagged deep into left center field
and that one is out of here big time
contact there by simeon a three-run home
run and just like that toronto with two
outs and nobody on
proceeds to score four runner at first
and the eighth man to come up in the
inning after two men are out and no one
on
and the swing of the miss it gets away
and the runner is going to reach panda
goes to second guriel junior reaches and
danny janssen coming up
that's strike three call
nine bend come to the plate toronto
scores four it's going to be left-hander
stephen matson how about the start that
he is off to three starts he's gone at
least six innings and giving up just one
earned run in all three
the ground ball backing up at third and
panic has it bounced off his glove
here's diaz heading for second
and the rays have a little something
here right off the bat one ball two
strikes so the right-handed batting of
rosarina
one two and a well-located fastball near
the inside corner to ring him up one
down now austin meadows would be as its
second one out
and a swing and a broken about base hit
into shallow left field diaz is going to
make the turn head home throw on a
bounce and they got him at the plate
glorial throws out diaz at home play
andy diaz i believe hesitated around
third i think he recognized that curios
got a strong arm but four nothing blue
jays bottom two one down for the third
baseman the left hand hitting joey
wendell 02 and a swing and a miss looked
like a change-up down and in and he gets
him two down
fastball at the knees for strike three
called and it's a three up three down
second inning for stephen mats to the
third and saint pete so two outs of the
base is empty and there's joe panic and
the pitch had its way swinging and
missing another 55-footer this one
knocked down by mejia he throws the
first and that's the fifth strikeout for
tyler's last now he puts the blue jays
down in order for the first time
four-nothing blue jays two on two out
bottom of the third so here is austin
meadows
and he got a swing and a miss and a
slider away fifth strikeout already for
matt's through three scoreless innings
so with one out here is danny jansen
janssen struck out looking to win the
first
strike three called again and
jansen knew it he's up to old for 26 now
two outs here in the fourth inning and
back to the top of the order we go
swung out and missed strike three that's
seven strikeouts for tyler glass now
we'll go to the bottom of the fourth
mike rosa will eat things off
lifts a fly ball to left center field
this ball's well hit gorial
and he's got it boy he juggled it for a
moment almost popped out of his glove
but he hangs onto it for the out
back-to-back errors by the shet and now
panic and the rays have second and third
and still with two outs and willie
adamus coming up to the plate
and a swinging fly ball right center
field richie
makes the catch on the edge of the track
twisting and turning a little bit but
that'll be out number three as the two
who reached on airs are left aboard top
of the fifth at tropicana field the blue
jays lead four to nothing
swing and miss
popping away
but the recovery made by mejia in the
throw
in
time now here's teles lifting a high
fly ball
where is it where is it oh coming over
from left the rose arena made the catch
kirbyr lost it
kierbyer was coming in from center
margot
behind him in center and suddenly out of
left comes a rosarena if that doesn't
fire you up i'm not sure what will now
they have met at first and second with
nobody out in the fifth and randy
rosarina is at the plate
that's gonna help long shot
deep left center
babies gone
home
[Music]
[Applause]
and he knew it too by the way if you do
that after you connect you it had better
go
and it did four three j's going to the
top of the sixth and they'll send up
randall gritsching
is well hit left center field he's
giving it a ride and it's gone home run
number three on the season for gretchen
and it is 5-3 blue jays by randall for
some reason he has three hits against
glass now and all three have been home
runs nine strikeouts tonight lourdes
curiel jr is a pitch swing on and foul
tempt into the mid of mehia strike three
guriel strikes out ten strikeouts five
three blue jays going bottom six
chatwood will face the bottom third of
the order
swung on diving stop guerrero underhands
to chatwood covering and they will get
him what a good play by vlady to get the
out this is why you don't move laddie
guerrero off the first base he has
really become comfortable over there and
he's always had good hands he's going to
the bottom of the ninth inning rafael
dolis ready to work he's finds
themselves down to their final out pitch
on the way
and a fastball grounded to short bechet
has it throw to first pulls guerrero off
the bag but he puts the tag on diaz
going by
and the blue jays will win it they
secure a victory at the drop